esta vez me voy a tomar a fx a efe de x
como la siguiente función va a ser la
función x + 7 esto elevado al cubo y
esto a su vez le voy a quitar 1 y
también me voy a tomar la función gdx la
función de x y voy a decir que esta va a
ser la función a se me ocurre la raíz
cúbica déjame ponerlo así la raíz cúbica
de mx1 de x + 1 y bueno después a esto
le voy a quitar 7 y lo que quiero hacer
en este vídeo es evaluar cuánto va a ser
efe deje de x
de déjame ponerlo así efe
de gtx y también quiero evaluar cuánto
es g de fx es decir me voy a tomar la
composición de funciones g de f de x y
como siempre te invito a que pausas el
vídeo y veas si tú puedes resolver esto
por tu cuenta muy bien entonces primero
evaluamos
efe deje de x y que significa efe deje
de x bueno esto significa que ahora
nuestra entrada va a ser de x o dicho de
otra manera que cada vez que veamos una
x en fx la vamos a reemplazar con gdx
entonces
efe gx a quien va a ser igual bueno va a
ser igual y déjame ver si me cabe aquí
esto me va a quedar como abro paréntesis
y después viene una equis así que el
lugar de la equis voy a poner a todo gtx
qué es la raíz cúbica muy bien de x1 de
x más 1 ok ya esto hay que quitarle 7 le
quitamos 7 y después la función fx me
dicen que le tenemos que sumar 7 le
tenemos que sumar 7 después todo esto
elevarlo al cubo y después quitarle uno
de lujo observa que lo único que hice
fue reemplazar cada equis que tenía en
fx por gd x porque me estoy tomando efe
deje de x y entonces en lugar de esta x
voy a poner la raíz cúbica de x + 1
menos 7 muy bien ahora veamos si podemos
simplificar esto un poco y lo primero
que veo es que aquí tengo menos 7 y aquí
tengo más 7 lo cual se reduce muy bien y
solamente me queda esta parte de aquí
déjame ponerlo con un color neutro me va
a quedar
raíz cúbica la raíz cúbica de x + 1 esto
a su vez elevado al cubo y después le
quitamos 1 ahora bien observa lo
siguiente si tú tienes la raíz cúbica de
x + 1 y después lo llevas al cubo bueno
pues esto esto es simplemente x + 1 esto
es simplemente x + 1 y después dice que
le tenemos que quitar 1 y bueno más uno
menos uno también se va y entonces puedo
decir que mi respuesta de fx va a ser
simplemente x perfecto ahora qué te
parece si trabajamos con g de fx ya que
va a ser igual esta expresión déjame
ponerlo aquí esto va a ser igual y bueno
ahora lo voy a escribir la siguiente
manera no lo hice nuestra primera parte
del ejercicio porque lo olvidé
pero aquí quiero ser mucho más claro lo
primero que voy a hacer es en lugar de
escribir esta x que tengo aquí voy a
escribir
efe
y después voy a reemplazar por la
función es decir para hacerlo mucho más
claro lo tendrías que hacer la siguiente
manera pones la raíz cúbica de y bueno
primero te encuentras con una equis así
que voy a poner aquí
fx df de x + 1
más y después a esto hay que restarle 7
lo único que estoy haciendo es
reemplazando las x por fx muy bien y
ahora sí voy a sustituir lo que vale fx
y ponerlo aquí adentro entonces me va a
quedar lo siguiente esto va a ser igual
a la raíz cúbica de quien bueno déjame
ponerlo así fx es lo mismo que todo esto
que tenemos aquí así que lo voy a poner
x + 7 esto elevado al cubo y después hay
que quitarle 1 muy bien y después dice
que hay que sumarle 1 hay que sumarle 1
y al final de todo esto le restamos 7 de
lujo y ahora observa para nuestra suerte
- 11 estos dos se van y me va a quedar
la raíz cúbica de x 7 elevado al cubo y
después hasta el final le restamos 7
pero observamos la raíz
kubica de x 7 elevado al cubo todo esto
se simplifica a x 7 porque la raíz
cúbica se cancelaría con este cubo que
tenemos aquí entonces de todo esto que
tengo aquí solamente me va a quedar x +
7 y después tenemos que hay que quitarle
7 muy bien pero estos dos se van y
solamente me quedo con x solamente me
quedo con esta parte que tengo aquí que
es x así que aquí tenemos algo muy
interesante
efe deje de x nos da x y gdf x también
nos da x entonces en este caso tenemos a
x ya está x la ponemos en la función
pensemos primero aunque la ponemos en la
función g déjame ponerlo justo así lo
cual nos da
v x
x y después esto lo ponemos en la
función f en la función f y observa que
nos dio el resultado x regresamos a x
fue como un ciclo hicimos un viaje en
círculos y lo mismo sucede en este otro
caso cuando teníamos a x ya x lo
poníamos a dentro de la función f lo
ponemos a dentro de la función f lo cual
por cierto sabemos que nos daba amd fx y
después a fx lo poníamos adentro de la
función y lo ponemos a dentro de la
función g y obteníamos de nuevo x es
decir hacíamos un ciclo de nuevo tenemos
nuestro viaje en círculos recuerda esta
es la entrada en la función esa es la
salida de mi función y después ésta se
vuelve la entrada en mi función le
aplicamos la función g y esa es la
salida de la función g
y bueno estas dos son funciones
compuestas pero otra forma de ver esto
sería lo siguiente si tú tienes por aquí
al conjunto de todas las posibles
entradas de tus funciones compuestas y
por acá tenemos todas las posibles
salidas y bueno por aquí te tomas a
equis déjame ponerlo aquí aquí tengo a
equis y le aplicamos no sé se me ocurre
la función g llegamos hasta este punto
aquí tenemos a gd x lo que hicimos fue
aplicar la función g pero ahora se hace
de x le aplicamos la función
efe que es lo que pasa me regresa de
nuevo a x aquí lo que estoy haciendo es
aplicándole efe am g de x y me lleva de
regreso a x y también nos dicen de esta
manera si tú tienes esa equis y le
aplica esa función g
x hdx y después más veamos a gdx con la
función
efe el mapeo de fx va a ser de nuevo
equis y viceversa si nosotros nos
sumamos a equis y le aplicamos por aquí
déjame ponerlo así la función f primero
déjame ver que lleguemos aquí a efe de x
lo que estoy haciendo es mapeando a x
con la función f para que me dé f x y xi
después más veamos a fx con la función g
de nuevo regresamos a x por aquí
tendrías de reponerlas y la función g
que la vamos a aplicar a efe
y bueno como estamos haciendo un ciclo o
un viaje en círculos entonces podemos
decir que las funciones f y g son
funciones inversas entre sí y entonces
podemos escribir que fx lo voy a poner
aquí efe de x es lo mismo que la función
inversa deje de x la función inversa
deje de x y viceversa gdx gv x es lo
mismo que la función inversa voy a tomar
su respectivo color que la función
inversa de f
y ya está espero que todo esto lo hayas
disfrutado bastante